david bonjour alors qu'est ce qui
suscite précisément le mécontentement de
ses agents de la police scientifique
eh bien les vielles c'est le statut de
sédentaires qui suscite la colère des
policiers scientifiques et techniques
aujourd'hui ils réclament un statut un
actif comme leurs collègues de la police
nationale
un cortège entre 400 et 500 personnes
ans s'est élancé à du 7e arrondissement
de paris pour se rendre vers
saint-augustin nous sommes presque
arrivés au point de dispersion de la
manifestation je me trouve actuellement
avec xavier des peker organisateurs de
la manifestation
si vous deviez tirer un bilan de cette
manifestation qu'elle serait t'il bilan
est positif sachant que on a quand même
un cinquième de nos collègues policiers
scientifiques d effectif total qui ont
été présents donc ça montre bien qu'on a
on a vraiment un ras-le-bol
depuis des années on nous on fait des
promesses on nous dit qu'on va résoudre
ce problème statutaire et on le voit
rien dire on a eu des ministères qui ont
essayé de travailler là dessus il ya
toujours eu le quelque chose qui
manquait en attendant on a des gens qui
sont sur le terrain qui sont
opérationnels preuve qu'on est
opérationnel quand on fait on exerce le
droit de grève
ça pose problème pour les hiérarchies
locales on a des pressions sur les
collègues ce qu'on dénonce d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
que voyez on a on a un gros prix
quiproquos chez nous on a gilet
pare-balles et agip heures bal c'est pas
anodin quand on vous le donne c'est bien
parce qu'il ya des risques de blessures
par balles et par arme blanche alors
justement vous mettez en avant aussi les
conditions de travail qui sont pénibles
et dangereuse puisque vous parlez de ce
gilet pare-balles en question ce qu'est
ce qui est paradoxal et pourtant le
gouvernement récemment nous a toujours
pas entendus comment vous comptez faire
dans l'avenir justement pour se faire
entendre de castaner notamment du
ministre de l'intérieur
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on va
continuer ce genre de mouvement
continuer les manifestations on a on a
des collègues vont essayer un petit peu
comme à l'image des avocats ou les
pompiers on va on va on va demander à
continuer ce genre de mobilisation
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on nous entend
pas ça fait très longtemps qu'on
n'entend pas mes collègues et voilà on
est déterminé sa saveur que dans la
police scientifique
on a eu voilà on a eu très peu
d'épisodes de grève
ç'a toujours été un jour là on rentre
dans la quatrième semaine de
contestation
c'est inédit c'est inédit sur la plupart
des services
on n'a pas les chiffres du ministère le
ministère ne nous étonne pas grosso modo
la 80% de perturbations dans les
services
et ça cette source des ces fameuses
hiérarchie locale
merci beaucoup xavier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions vous l'aurez compris la
mobilisation va se poursuivre et la
manifestation va toucher à sa fin dans
quelques minutes
en tout cas le mouvement de protestation
en face à ce statut actifs perdure
depuis des années pour cette section de
la police scientifique et technique